alex duféal bonjour bonjour vous vous
présenter aux élections législatives
dans la circonscription du nord au nom
de combat ouvrier ce n'est pas la
première fois d'ailleurs c'est pas votre
première candidature aux élections d'une
manière générale et à des législatives
pourquoi vous présentez-vous cette fois
là pour ces législatives 2022 oui alors
pour ajouter c'est faire un temps dans
le camp des travailleurs donc pourquoi
parce que ça ne va pas les la martinique
est divisé en deux d'un côté la
martinique des riches il maintenir des
pauvres et les pauvres subissent quant à
la politique des riches idées
capitalistique au gros capitalisme on se
présente pour dire qu' il ya des grèves
qui se feront en martinique à la poste
et le net qui montre que les
travailleurs se bat contre les
conditions de vie donc il faut amplifier
lutte là c'est boussard et nous sommes
tout ça que je me présente en pj
solitaire que c'est le mouvement se
transforme en force politique et c'est
pour ça que je me présente pour dieu le
travail d'exprimer leur politique par
rapport à la situation actuelle alors
vous dénoncez un certain nombre de
situations de conditions sociales et
économiques en martinique mais quels
sont les deux ou trois propositions ou
projets prioritaires que vous auriez si
vous êtes élu député pour notre
territoire pour la martinique parce que
vous seriez député de la martinique élu
dans la sarthe qui secoue la
circonscription nord mais néanmoins
député de la martinique voisine un bain
c'est ça s'articule en trois thèmes
quand leur chômage il faut la
répartition du travail entre tous et pau
aucune retraite aucune pension ou que
salaires ne doit être inférieur à 2000
on est passé là c'est le minimum qu'on
peut vivre actuellement est aussi le
contrôle des décomptes des entreprises
pour dévoiler le secret commercial pour
pouvoir voir combien d'argent les traits
que le patron de rock legault
capitalisme dans la caisse parce que
vous avez la brasserie lorraine par
exemple qui clique est en redressement
judiciaire mais combien d'argent on sait
pas le compte on sait pas qu est ce qu
on sait pas combien d'argent qui sont
prises on donne aux actionnaires
externes on voyait on sait pas hélas si
on se lance et ça
on sera surpris de voir que l'argent
dégouline et en plus de ça il n'arrête
pas d'être ils n'arrivent pas d'être
subventionné avec nos impôts donc on en
a marre les travailleurs nomades qu'ils
me le disent c'est que le dise moi je ne
sais que le porte parole des
travailleurs alors concernant la
situation les problématiques rencontrées
dans la 2e circonscription donc celle du
nord dans laquelle vous présenter et
bien là aussi quelles seraient vos deux
ou trois priorités à à mettre en oeuvre
si vous étiez élu député le nord sud les
séquelles du colonialisme le travail les
ouvriers que les petits commerçants
victimes des séquelles du colonialisme
et en plus de ça ils sont victimes du
chlordécone où on voit des capitalistes
bkf le doux nom mais d'autres aussi on
connaît le nom qui ont empoisonné
volontairement la population parce qu'il
savait que ça allait un poison n'est
fait ils sont tranquilles en la justice
n'allait et nelly condamne pas alors
quoi ils disaient que c'était pour
sauver les récoltes de bâle ville a
menacés par un champignon oui là comme
s'était d'abord comme leur poche ils ont
vu passer ya même un qui m'a dit que oui
mais ça rapporte beaucoup d'argent à une
maladie je préfère ne pas du tout parce
que j'attends un moment majeur il me l'a
dit ça rapporte beaucoup d'argent le
cloud chlordécone alors non voilà une
situation une situation aussi où il ya
40%
pedretti pour ses marques mais tu vois
la population qui vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté dans
le nord c'est une priorité priorité il
ya des gens qui n'a même pas 400 euros
pour yves c'est une priorité alors les
promesses électorales et ça suffit comme
ça parce qu'on arrête pas parce que
pendant ce temps pendant qu'elle ait
l'épaule les députés sortants ils ont
fait des promesses électorales des
bâtons ils seulement ils s'en moquent
parce que et et continuent à y voir avec
les autres la cie les autres passent à
faire la même chose ceux qui pensaient
d'abord leur porsche alors qu'il faut
une force politique pour contrebalancer
se situe à chaleur précisément alex
duféal candidat dans la circonscription
du nord au nom de combat ouvrier qu'avez
vous à dire pour conclure d'essentiel
pour convaincre les électrices et
électeurs du nord de la martinique de la
côte atlantique à la côte caraïbe
j'appelle les travailleurs et les
paysans révoltés les ouvriers les petits
commerçants à exprimer leur colère pour
dire qu'ils en ont assez des situations
qui fait que c'est toujours les riches
qui sont toujours riches et les pauvres
ils ont toujours exprimé avec nous qu'il
faut voter pour dire voter leur camp les
travailleurs à l'exil ferrals et jean
étienne bredas mon supérieur pour dire
qu'ils nous ont assez et qui finissent
un jour doivent constituer une force
politique pour contrebalancer
contrebalancer la situation voilà ce que
je ne le dis il faut qu'il s'exprime il
faut pas qu'ils s'assument s'abstiennent
excusez moi
donc je peux terminer pour dire je
répète encore une fois votez pour votre
camp le camp des travailleurs combat
ouvrier lutte ouvrière le camp de
travailleurs et voilà notre situation
actuelle pour faire exprimer leur colère
par rapport à la situation
merci alex 10 fait elle
[Musique]